woohoo good afternoon good morning good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel on just a
just a hangout video we're just chilling
we're just G to talk about whatever the
hell we want to talk about so if you've
got questions throw them in to the
commentary I don't know why I'm pointing
that way because on my screen comments
are on that side but actually really
doesn't matter but anyway we are um
being joined by The Invisible
Man uh Tommy as well who's from the
companion it's very difficult to do this
because it's in reflection so shut up
out stormy do a great and now stormy
Bear say hello everybody except hello
hello welcome Tomy thank you very much
for having me this is great yeah oh well
fellow Manchester United fan and we've
got to pull together in that hour of
need you know what if if we didn't lose
sometimes the wins wouldn't feel good
and you've we lose Win Lose or Draw
you've just got to back your team it's
it is what it is saw someone say that um
ten hog might be the first manager to
get sacked the same month he wins
manager of the
month oh man I'll just say hello to
everybody Sarah hey Laura hi chillan hey
Carrie hey Daisy hey once more to the
old
orifice and um yeah and hello everybody
right um we met didn't we Telly recently
when um when we appeared on the
companion basically such
as a man united fan we've started
bitching at each other when every
time through Messenger oh for [__]
sake um but tell everybody else a little
bit about yourself how did you get
involved in the companion um what do you
do for him yeah so I mean I was uh in a
university uh studying film always
wanted to work in film and uh I did an
internship in my second to last year at
Studio canal in the marketing department
doing some you
fairly fun stuff there um I sort of
realized it was also just m and I could
have been selling toilet paper and not
films and it was the same job kind of
fell out of love with that very quickly
and um in my uh well as I was finishing
my final year I was looking for other
internships and I found a production
company that were looking for someone
that watched Stargate and I was you know
I was like I love Stargate that's that's
weird so I applied for that um and it
was a production company called The
Narrative and we were basically the
production team behind Stargate command
mgm's Stargate command um and then
unfortunately MGM shut that down it was
a little experiment that to some degrees
worked others degree other degrees
didn't um it turned out what we didn't
know at the time is that MGM were
looking to be sold to someone else so uh
turns out that was Amazon but uh so they
shut down the Stargate command project
unfortunately but we was like this is
great we've got this massive community
of Stargate fans we want to keep making
this amazing content so much of it is
sitting on a hard drive that we can't
release because MGM onet and we got some
really really good stuff on there which
is such a shame but we're like you know
we've got a we've made some really good
relationships we've you know there's a
lot of great fans out there we want to
keep doing something so uh Nick and
Lawrence from the companion both flew
out to Los Angeles they they met with uh
one of the presidents at MGM and said
well we want to buy a Stargate command
off you uh and he said oh great uh don't
do that though it's it's going to be
massively overpriced it's not going to
be worth it and you're going to have to
deal with MGM League all the time um
which is was frustrating for us at
Stargate command because there'd be
things like we couldn't mention Warner
Brothers properties so if we write an
article about Jason Mamoa and Atlantis
and we can't mention Aquaman and the
king of Atlantis it was just like this
weird thing and they were like no just
be independent it will be way better for
you way cheaper and you can do a lot
more we was like yeah okay let's let's
do that so we we started the companion
at this point I was hired on fulltime
and uh yeah we was just building the
companion and that's it's been about
four years now since we started I think
the companion launched a little bit
after that but we was working behind the
scenes for about a year before we
launched so yeah that's kind of my
journey to the
companion yeah and then um I assume
that's why because I know like um Jenny
styven and people like that and that's
how you how you how you know them and
that's yeah we we was working with Jenny
uh every week um with star command and
then kept a really good relationship
with her and have carried that on since
I actually met her in person for the
first time at Dragon Con in Atlanta a
couple of months ago so that that was
great J Jenny's the best yes anyone
who's met Jenny says the exact same
thing that she's just the
best yeah it's still eating the ribs
from last week uh Young Harris here
mugged yeah you've got no volume Harris
can hear you I realized that now I was
trying to come back in him beat I met
jinny last week at ComiCon she's the
best person ever she I'm literally
wearing her shirt right now and she she
texted me yesterday the ribs when I made
her sorry oh good good if I gotta send
her an apology if you mugged Jenny St
even for a t-shirt no she gave me a free
shirt she literally she had an author
with her and the author gave me a free
book stormy would have died uh she like
a whole a free book and a whole bunch of
merch it was insane it was it was just
really fun congrats sweetest people you
did give her food it is the way to a
woman's heart if you give her I mean
barbecue as well I mean dude I'd give
you free Stu I'd give you a child if you
gave me barbecue
basically I know which one I'd give you
to immediately it was great her husband
was just as excited as she was which was
hilarious they didn't have to cook for a
week which was
good that's great amazing amazing but
yeah it's just just an absolutely lovely
lovely woman I can't I can't say enough
nice things about it and um she's always
got time which is nice so
um while you've been working on the
companion then when has there been any
highlights anything that really jumps
out mind you think God man that was
weird yeah there's been a lot I guess
the the two I always say my two
highlights uh the first one's producing
Stargate AI all three of them that was
uh such an amazing experience to work so
closely with Brad and with Lawrence
[__] from Google this is before AI like
blew up like it has now as well it was a
really crazy experiment at the time and
we we were hoping it it wouldn't work in
the best way as in like we was hoping it
would be terrible which it was and then
well the first one was first was aw
seeing seeing Richard De Anderson read
those lines in like his most like Jack
performance ever is like the craziest
thing that that happened uh and it was
really really fun working with him so I
say stug at AI as a whole was um a great
highlight and the the other one um was
the podcast series I did with Brad we we
did 10 episodes of a podcast series
called Brad W's conversations in sci-fi
and um I've you know loved Brad's Brad's
show for ages and I I used to really
want to be a screenwriter until I found
out I was a terrible writer um so
getting to work closely with him on that
was really really fun and that podcast
series is kind of like no other as well
because I always say it's like you're at
a pub and Brad Wright and whoever the
guest is that week is just sitting on a
table next to you and you're just kind
of listening in it doesn't feel like a
normal interview you're just kind of
like listening to them hang out and
catch up and that was so much fun so
yeah those are my two highlights with
the
companion I have to admit chatting to
Brad right I I know I keep telling this
but I don't care um Brad rght joined me
or or or followed me on Twitter on my
birthday
and it was just the best thing I'm like
my kids are like giving me like hey here
you go this here's A500 watch I hope you
like it [__] that follow me
today anything Brad w't follow me on
Twitter today so he's great he's he's
he's so funny and um he's just he's so
talented as well like even when you look
at uh like Travelers like he's just an
excellent show as well like he's a he's
really really great writer I just
started watching it again
after I watched it first time around
um I didn't love it actually as much
first time around I'm appreciating it
more this time around I don't know I
think maybe it's a bit older or
something I don't know but um I don't
think I quite I think I went into it
though hoping it would be like is this
gonna be like Stargate and then it
wasn't I was a bit disappointed maybe
yeah it's kind of got a high sci-fi
concept the whole obviously time travel
you know element to it but when you
watch episode to episode it's kind of
like just a cool spy Thriller like it's
kind of not a Sci-Fi show like episode
to episode which I
I get what you're saying once you kind
of tune into that you're like oh okay
this is just a great spy show like I'm
into this now yeah
yeah like how many shows though or
movies in particular though you you walk
in on with an
expectation and then you're disappointed
I mean how many I can't tell you how
many times I've watched the film at the
cinema I'm G I don't like that but then
I watch it six months later on streaming
like this is great why why why didn't I
yeah I thought I thought that might have
been the case with um the last Thor
movie but it wasn't it was terrible yeah
I get it the opposite way a lot as well
where I walk out the C while go and that
was like the greatest film I've ever
seen that was so good and then I I watch
it again I'm like well that sucks I just
must have been swept up by like that
moment but I that was not good I'm with
you I do that same thing it's that Rosie
tined glasses walking out that theater
and then six months later you're like oh
damn yeah I remember I had that with The
Hobbit when I first saw The Hobbit in
like 2012 whenever it was I was like oh
my God it's like it's just as good as
the Lord of the Rings if not better and
then I sort of thought about it saw it
again I was like oh no this isn't great
and then I saw it again and I was like
actually it's pretty
bad I've never watched it I've never
watched all three I watched the first
half of the first one and I didn't get
past the um singing bit and I just sort
of like I think I'm GNA do some ironing
just
yeah I'd love to live in the alternate
timeline where G delor was able to make
the two films for it you
know I would die for that yeah I'm sure
David huet would have got cast in it
somewhere as well as a as a dwarf or
something that would have been great
hilarious great for that David H should
be in everything this is also true yeah
yeah he's just one of those actors that
he's just ridiculously likable even that
film he did which really if you break it
down it's it's I don't want to be mean
about it because actually I love it
um but it's not the best produced thing
I've ever seen oh dog's breakfast dog's
breakfast but it was such a clever idea
such a I like it I think it's fun I
think yeah you can tell the smaller
budget and stuff but I think it's uh I
think it's fun the writing is really
good and the you know you can tell the
cast obviously all know each other and
have fun together and stuff so I think
that really comes through tell there's
absolutely no budget because it was
basically star Atlantis was on break and
he got everybody in
it you see like Joe fanger being pushed
on like oh what what what what what am I
doing
oh um but oh it's it's it's it's great
it's is a lovely movie but um but yeah
so what so yeah you love
Stargate so you're gonna be popular here
we like that as well I don't I don't
know if you've ever noticed but we talk
about it occasionally you can't shut up
about it let's just be honest this is
like you know it's we're into
it it is very good which you know so it
makes sense
what are your thoughts about maybe what
we're going to have in the next 12
months 18 months what do you think might
happen or not happen or well there was
the report that came out uh I know you
spoke about it as well and a reporter I
know was also talking about it with
obviously the Total Recall the Legally
Blonde you know all those kind of things
um and Stargate was on the list and it
it just makes sense James Bond is a
hugely valuable property um people have
have been having bidding wars for it
every few years for decades and um it it
makes sense that Amazon want their hands
on James Bond but there's there's
they're sitting on a gold mine of other
content there so it only makes sense
that something comes soon what that is I
I don't know what I hope it is is
something with Brad Wright at least as a
consultant on the project but um I
wouldn't be surprised if they just did
kind of a a film thing and it's not what
we're all hoping hoping for but I hope
I'm wrong the the thing about the
Hollywood in general is it's so Trend
based and if one thing comes out and
just you know becomes a trend then
everyone will just follow suit all the
plans that existed will be thrown out
the window and everyone will start
making new plans and you know all all it
takes is one Legacy show to come back
and do really really well maybe Battle
Star Galactica or something comes back
and does really really well and then
Amazon start panicking and going quick
why haven't we got 10 Stargate scripts
to choose from yet you know so who who
knows really well I I would say actually
that like Picard season 3 might have
been a bit of a catalyst for legacy
stuff coming back and I mean the rumors
we keep hearing was that it was movie
movie movie that's what Amazon had been
arguing for 12 months that they were
saying we we just want to do a film um
the way it was explained to me was that
basically Amazon have got a budget to do
five or six cinema movies and they were
like one of them would be Stargate and
and that was as much as and it was was
as far as that's what was going to be
announced at San die ComicCon but now
I'm hearing like a series might actually
be they might they might switch because
stuff keeps not doing very well at the
cinema they can't seem to it it seems to
me anyway that nobody can seem to judge
what's going to do well at the cinema
and what isn't um they films that are
expected to do brilliantly bomb and then
Barbie comes along and makes $2 billion
dollar and and people thought that was
going to bomb at one point um but um so
yeah um and then
so so maybe but then I do wonder if
Picard season 3 came along and it was
just so popular
um that maybe that made them stop and
think you know we've got we've actually
got a TV show like that that people will
watch um yeah maybe we should do that
instead and then spend a lot less
money yeah I think the streaming model
makes so much more sense for TV shows
like the way they do it with
movies I don't know the um the ins and
outs of their financial model behind the
scenes but it it feels like they're just
lighting money on fire sometimes when
they spend stupid money on these big
films and they don't put them in the
cinema or they put them in the cinema
for you know two weekends to qualify for
an award or you know something like that
and it just feels
put whereas TV shows it's it it really
does make sense like and you you know
they've proved of various different
shows that you can do Bing model you can
do the week by week and it it doesn't
really matter people still tune in look
at the Star Wars shows people tune in
every week for those and it becomes
Global conversation you know it it
totally
works and I rather having subscribers is
more important than minutes really um
before it would be advertising
advertising was the thing if you want a
big if you have a big show more
advertisers will spend more money to
have the in their ad breaks and so the
show makes money um now it's it's all
about subscription numbers Netflix can
basically put out or to try after well
they haven't really done anything other
than maybe stranger things I don't think
Netflix have done anything particularly
successful for three or four
years I can't yeah I don't think the New
Black Mirror did well but Black Mirror
was very good before um yeah but that
with black mirror is a couple of years
off now but um I I for me I think
Paramount Disney and a couple of other
streamer Services have been have
actually been doing better product I
keep telling you I think actually
Paramount do some of the best stuff on
there it might be my favorite streaming
service at the moment I think it's
brilliant I would say apple as well
Apple have been absolutely crushing with
Ted lasso for for one but then their
sci-fi offerings been like fantastic oh
my God and was it what's the next one
coming out on Apple TV is it
constellation or something uh oh I want
to say that's right but um it looked a
bit the advert looks a bit like gravity
to me the way it's um the tone of it
sort of thing but yeah it does look good
and that's they've spent a bit of money
on that as well and Foundation 3 I think
you know got to go ahead and starts
filming here a month or so uh yeah apple
and especially the Sci-Fi offerings is
just out of the park yeah I really
enjoyed S I thought that was a great
great show that's still need to watch it
looks so good and they're making Cinema
quality movies as well I mean last year
was that um Chris Evans movie that spy
thing they did it's quite a good film
don't get me wrong two years ago they
won they won picture with with kod that
that was um that was an apple like all
all the streaming platforms were racing
to win best picture that you know
they're all putting out there I think
Netflix came close to Roma a few years
before that and then Apple kind of
entered the the race late and then won
it first so yeah I think they're quietly
gonna become Giants correct me if I'm
wrong but isn't Killers the flower Moon
Apple
yeah you might be right I think an apple
so they very well might do it
twice well the thing is they seem to
they they just seem to have the attitude
of quality of a quantity which now all
the other streaming services have have
clicked on to all they I think they were
all sort of do in the Netflix model
Netflix model was just we just throw as
much on there as we can and let people
binge they'll find TV shows they've
forgotten about in years or stuff and we
can even throw stuff from North Korea
and things and people will watch it and
Disney definitely had the attitude of
just throw everything on there and then
they just sort of realized that these
servers are costing us a bloody Fortune
maybe we should think but I do think
that there's definitely been some TV
shows and I think Netflix have been a
bit naughty in the last few years in
that they canceled a lot of shows after
the first season but it probably shows
they shouldn't have green l in the first
place they just it was it was content
wasn't it it was the content Wars rather
than the quality Wars yeah I think I
think Netflix are very data driven I
think they probably have a perfect
formula for these sorts of things of
like okay we can see how many people
have watched it if we spend any more
money we'll end up losing money and I
feel like a lot of their decisions are
based around that whereas Apple kind of
of the mentality of let's just give
really talented people like money and
freedom and then it's turned out some
amazing amazing shows and films and
things like that so hopefully that
becomes the trend yeah so horses is
insane you know slow Aston is just oh my
God I can't stand it when he farts but I
can't miss an episode yeah I mean you
know yeah but that's just all leading
into the character isn't that he's such
a LoveHate character that the farting
and um smoking drinking his hair is
disgusting oh you just want to bathe him
right I mean it is just so outr I mean
when he farts I can almost taste it he's
such a good actor oh he's he's one of
the greatest actors of Our Generation as
far as I'm concerned he's phenomenally
good um but um yeah so Matt's just
appeared in the um in the comment in the
comments he's not very well he would he
wanted to be with us and he want very
much wanted to
have so he's poorly um so he's got one
of those calls that's bloody going
around at the moment everybody's got um
except probably you Americans because
you know you live in California so
doesn't get called
probably D where the hell have you
been weird J you telling me it was 100
degrees Fahrenheit not long ago that was
like six months ago man what is it now
it it's like in the 60s it's it's never
cold out here but it gets weirdly chilly
because it's so Breezy I think it's the
coastal Breeze that does it but it's
really
not 38 degrees here in the sunny warm
desert of New
Mexico engl oh God Jesus
I don't know Fahrenheit we don't use it
it's completely
irrelevant let me look that up 32 is
zero so it's that's like one or two
degrees for you right you said 33
33 it it's
probably oh see two five six uh it's
probably three degrees Celsius okay
that's pretty cold okay I get that um
so throw out to everybody really what do
we what do we really think the future of
streaming is because obviously it's
tripping a little bit at the moment
there's some stumbling and should
Stargate go on streaming because Amazon
have the opportunity to put it somewhere
else but will it be
streamed I I think the future probably
involves um weirdly I think it would
involve some consolidation of I reckon
some of the big streamers will start
working together kind of like how Amazon
do when they have
I don't I don't know what it's like in
America but over here at least we have a
lot of different streamers through
Amazon Prime that's how we kind of get
those things yeah so I wouldn't be
surprised if there was more
consolidation like that because it feels
like the bubble's going to burst and
then the other thing is I wouldn't be
surprised if more um advertising models
become options with streamers and we
essentially just start going back to
what like the the old like Network model
was and we just like slowly but surely
realized that it's the same as it was 15
years ago we just didn't even realize it
happened the internet instead over the
internet I wouldn't be surprised if it
that went that way just as a random
prediction but yeah I think we're going
to see a lot more grouping of things as
well Disney are doing it at the moment
they've dumped um so now you can get
Disney Plus Hulu will be on there um
what's the sports thing they own ESPN
ESPN yeah well we we don't have that so
ESPN and isn't there something else as
well that's like an bu bundle for Disney
that might be that that might be it
might be Hulu's going on or Fox as well
I mean foxes was dump into star so you
could argue that's sort of been bundled
together as well really because I mean
most of Disney's content is is really
Fox yeah oh n goo was the other one
National Geographic was the other
National Geographic National Geographic
one thank you so I mean um yeah I mean
there's so
much I I I think that's the model and I
think that's what Amazon are going for
um that that seems to be they want to be
where you go to get stuff rather than
being a provider else but Stargate new
series streamed on MGM plus will that
work I think so I think it makes sense I
think it would be a great um driver of
subscriptions for them as well I think
that would be a great way to I mean how
many um Stargate fans are there in the
world really like Millions right there's
probably yeah there probably two million
on Facebook um that have liked the page
or something like that a large
percentage of them are are coming back
to to watch a new show a proper new show
not like Origins which um obviously had
a limited budget and was online only but
like a proper Network show I think a lot
of people are checking out even out of
curiosity for the first
season what do you think went wrong with
Origins honestly it wasn't just the
budget I mean there was some quite
decent big sci-fi actors in that I mean
like
um
trer yeah
um Connor Connor yeah Connor trer was in
there he was quite big at the time and
there was a couple of others as well but
it's
still it wasn't great but nobody watched
it from day one it was almost like you
know it was the rejected draft for the
very first Indie movie you know it was
like oh no no no no no it was the the
writing I I think it died by the writing
it was just
it for something like Stargate it was
just I was really setback of how the
writing was I thought yeah well Tomy
that was your fault so yeah that was
before my
time I'll wash your hands of
that yeah yeah you should go into
politics no but mean did you have an
opinion on why it didn't work why was
the was it just that it was rushed and
not enough budget I'm not sure I mean
it's one of those things isn't it I mean
no one sets out to make anything bad uh
everything starts with the best of
intentions and a lot of people worked
really hard in it I'm sure and they were
I'm sure there were fans as well um May
maybe maybe they were fans as well but I
know some people that did work on it and
they certainly are massive fans um I
don't know I guess it's just really
really hard to make like great stuff so
like sometimes it just doesn't work
right which if anything just highlights
and elevates um the people that make
really good stuff because especially
when they do it consistently uh because
it's really not easy no that's my
diplomatic
answer yeah yeah no I I do wonder if
it's a little bit not before it's time
but I think the idea of going on the
internet the way it did as webisodes was
just illc conceived as well it just
wasn't um I know what they were thinking
because then like Netflix and everything
else you know it was almost like they
were trying to do as like a YouTube vid
Channel or something and it just
it would have done better if they'd done
it through
YouTube or something like that but um
yeah the trailer got um tons and tons
and tons of views like it was uh a
really like highly viewed video I can't
remember what it is now but I remember
it blowing up at the time and then that
just didn't translate to the platform
that you know MGM were trying to launch
Stargate command which uh if remember
rightly it was like $20 a year you get
access to Stargate Origins all the other
episodes of Atlantis Universe um and
then you get written content and audio
video content and it seemed like a
really good offering and I think Origins
was probably designed as like a you know
a lead gen tool for for that whole
platform and people just weren't ready
for that like maybe that was where the
disconnect was whereas if something like
Origins happened like you say just for a
YouTube channel and it was just for that
kind of content maybe it would have been
approached differently I don't
know yeah
it's just one of those things that seems
like I'm sure it seemed like a brilliant
idea when they were in an office um but
maybe it just
didn't I I know for me just a massive
Stargate fan and it never occurred to me
to join Stargate command I'm not even
sure I could here in the UK I must been
able yeah um I'm not I'm not even sure I
I was really aware of it um so that was
struggle that was the struggle yeah
honestly it's the struggle we have with
the companion still
uh it's it's just not easy that's where
the world has Chang every since Facebook
became massive the whole like consumer
Market is just competing for attention
it's just eyeballs and seconds is all
anyone's trying to track
these I don't know what's going on there
I think the microphone broke
repeating like one sentence that you
said I'm just going to drop you out a
sec I'll drop him out a sec and bring
him back let's see I was just getting
into the Rhythm man come on I was just
getting in the
Rhythm am I back yeah you're back that
sounds good you're gonna have to go
check that out later though you'll crack
up I was back in
the90s there's something to do with uh
the sound card in that old microphone
that um it does that sometimes it kind
of like cuts for a second and then just
like Rel Loops like a part of it that's
not the first time that's happened um
where did
I yeah probably yeah I am very Mac heavy
listening um where did I get up to you
probably remember it very
well I don't know what you're trying to
say but all you as Asis is acis um but
we were just laughing at
um I can't remember let just move on
probably wasn't probably wasn't very
insightful anyway it's
fine yeah about Origins something about
origin yeah I just like to say I've
watched it since um but uh and I I
didn't I didn't hate it I I've watched
the version that was sort of like
spliced together as if like to try and
make a movie it's a bit disjointed
because the way it was done that's the
only Vision I've seen um but I think
it's better like that than thing when
the way it was put together um Bob I
heard aist aist aist that is what I was
saying you're right
yeah if we if we play it backwards um is
you're like I love the devil yeah
there's a secret message
yeah um but you know I'm I'm I'm hopeful
for the future I'm hopeful that it does
seem that I say Amazon were dead set on
this movie idea but let's hope they they
um end they 97 I think it was 97% of
people that I asked on this channel said
no we just must have a series please um
and I just like it's cheaper we get more
of it and it's what the fans want and I
think Amazon are sensible enough more
than other Studios I think some I think
Studios they think we know what we want
Amazon do seem to sort of like go what
does the customer actually want and the
end of the day that's why they've gone
on to be the
biggest um you know like retailer on the
planet
by saying right what do you want and do
you want it right now okay and and
that's how they've done it something so
that's fingers
crossed
um it's a big year though now so 2024 is
a big year we're going to be seeing a
six-month Gap in movies and television
because of the
strikes um I don't think we've quite
seen that yet uh I think it's just about
to happen there's no Gap you just have
to go see movies that aren't giant
freaking Blockbusters for a few months
it'll be okay well well that means we
get back to True Cinema and art form
which will be all right it'll be okay
you're gonna you're gonna make me watch
films where they talk all the way
through damn
right know to blow up damn it I want an
alien to turn up and blow [__] up they
might it'll just be a little
cheaper wobbly walls and stuff um but I
said I think we have got a six months
where we're going to be a bit uh um for
stuff but uh and I don't think it'll
kick in until spring and then we'll
start seeing maybe a bit of a gap um but
television as well but I think that'll
that'll be gone and pass a bit quicker
but what is there anything that you guys
have seen that you're looking forward to
for the next 12
months D to uh for for me it's you know
new seasons of foundation uh hope I'd
like to see another um I can't wait to
watch out the the rest of For All
Mankind that's getting really
interesting I'm struggling with all
mankind I've started to watch it I find
it a little boring because it get
better I think so yeah yeah yeah I mean
it is I mean it's not gunfight well it
is gunfights in some in some cases
there's just some murder on the moon and
you know some treason and some really
shitty things that people do to each
other but yeah you know it's
okay and of course the AF mentioned
um constellation you know and um I hope
there's a Loki season 3 I'd like to see
how all that works out it's been out a
little while it's uh no no sorry no loky
season 2 wasn't it um yeah I can't
remember if there's gonna be a season
three I don't know if there is gonna be
because it was I mean only thing if if
we want to have a season three it'd be
like Thor walking up you know to him and
say well where the hell have you
been you want probably stroke his hair
or do some other dumbass thing we're g
to get another Thor movie and I tell you
what
um Thor movie this time a good Thor
movie please love of God well tanko TI
is not going to be directing it now and
it's basically say this because he's got
so many other projects on and he's doing
Star Wars and what have you I bet the
people over at Disney are going to be
sort of look like taer we love you
you're a
genius just check everything past us
though before you film it just you know
like just we just we just want to have a
look the screaming goats really just
bothered me to know where yeah
if furiosa furiosa is um I think that's
do you like that
trailer I I I think it's a bit weird
that we're having a Mad Max movie
without Mad Max in
it um was interesting um yeah um Fallout
I think fallout's going to be I think
that could be one of the big series of
the year I think that could be
good um if it's not I
mean everything they everything I've
seen so far looks like they they've
really stuck to the feel of the of the
the series um it's it's made by the guys
that made the boys and you can see that
from the trailer I'm watching the
trailer going I want to see what happens
the very next second after that because
if it's what I suspect from the boys
that's going to be like
blood
everywhere um yeah so I I think that'll
be that'll be interesting the boys is
coming back as well isn't it when's that
yeah be next
year trailers have start to drop for the
boys as well I couldn't I've tried so
hard to watch gen V I can't watch it it
started out get through you got it I
believe in you no it start it ran at a
thousand miles now and I'm just like I
don't know where it's going to go
after that I think it's it's got to a
point it was just shock factor for the
sake of shock factor
and it it turned me off I I see the
thought process there but I totally
disagree because the story is still just
so well told so well put together and
it's extremely meticulous meticulous I
can't even say that word meticulously
done there we go third time to charm uh
you're an
actor I get paid to say other people's
words not mine um but
uh it's just so well put together and
they do have the shock value but after
that initial shock value from that first
episode the entire season is just it
gives you room to breathe and I I
appreciate that so much from that series
because it can turn into just shock
value very easily and they do have that
like once an episode where like
something crazy does happen and that's
where their money spent for the episode
CGI wise typically but they let that
story breathe I love that I love
[Music]
it but I'll give it another go but the
boys the first season of the boys was my
favorite show when it came out I just I
love it was off the hook I was not
prepared for that I just couldn't handle
Carl 's accent I
was it was it was really bothering me I
just thought what at first I thought why
have they made butcher from like
Australia like why have they made
butcher Australia he's like an East
London he's meant to be C
and then he references Hometown in East
in East London and I was like oh he's
been he's been trying to do a cockney
accent this whole time that that is not
what I thought he was doing I didn't
actually realize that I thought he was
supposed to be Australian or or New
Zealander I've not tweaked that so he he
um what's it um Mary Poppins Mary
Poppins yeah well I'm from I'm from
Essex which is where everyone in East
London moved to when when they started
gentrifying it so it's very much like
mine and my family ja so maybe I'm like
more acutely like aware of it but it
really really bothered me I had to sort
of I just pretend he's Australian now
just pretend Australian it's
easier resident alien is coming back
we're getting the third season we've
started to see some um some add little
teasers for that now as well we um
fourth season where's that
stream sorry where's that stream I've
always wanted to watch it I just never
have oh I don't know I watch it over
here on Atlantic so
that tends to be a lot of HBO stuff from
us but I've have no idea what it but it
doesn't stream it network isn't it
okay but yeah I see on Atlantic
over um but yeah I just I just
love that it's it's Alan tudk just
basically it's just if Alan Tudi was an
alien that's exactly what we'd get and I
just I just think it might be my
favorite show I love the first season I
thought it got a bit there towards the
um second but then it really picked up
again uh Sarah wants to say sci-fi over
in there oh I I just Googled it Bob's
right it's on Prime it's I think it's
made by a Sci-Fi but it is on Prime it's
on Prime SFI
stuff I don't didn't watch it on Prime
here I'm sure I watch out on Atlantic
here it's been a little while though it
so might I might be wrong no it's
definitely on sky here because I
remember downloading it I've we got to
download things to Sky it's such a
nuisance you have to sit and wait for it
to download and I'm I just streaming man
Netflix has been doing it for 10
years um but anyway oh the penguin TV
show as well that I think that could be
that could be really interesting
um have you seen today that the Kurt
Russells answered rumors that he might
be in the new Superman movie and he's
just G yeah I'll Marlon Brando
it um hope not yeah I'm just like I what
do you guys think about the future of DC
I'm not sure I'm not optimistic you know
it's waiting to see what
happens I like Jes gone I think I mean
Guardians 3 was incredible I I
absolutely adored that film um so and I
really liked his Suicide Squad as well
um so I'm kind of optimistic to see what
he does obviously he's not directing
everything he's he's just going to be
sitting at the top but obviously doing
Superman so yeah I think I just kind of
we'll see what happens I'm I'm
open-minded I guess I haven't liked a
lot of the DC movies the last few years
so um I kind of don't really have high
expectations but you know sometimes when
you have low expectations you can be you
know mind blown so we'll
see yeah that is there's slightly two
different things I'm just so I didn't
love Guardians of the Galaxy 3 but I
might be need to watch it again I think
that might be one of those movies I went
in with very high expectations because I
love the first two and I haven't watched
it since it streamed actually um but
guard the first Guardians in particular
though that was one of those films that
you go in with almost no expectations
and just come out going that might be my
favorite Marv I I was uh all my friends
will tell me about this all the time I
was counting down the days for Guardians
because I was one of the I don't know 12
people that ever read that comic
book and I really really liked it and
they made a lot of changes but for the
better and I I really lik James gun as
well before that because uh super was
one of my favorite like little indie
films I thought it was like hilarious
with Ry Wilson um and then I watch
little bit
later is a great horror movie it's um
it's just um simple but attack the Slugs
basically just a load of slugs just
attack everyone but I it's such a good
film um that's that's the that I was
just like I can't I can't believe Nathan
fine didn't become a massive movie star
after that but it I think it bombed but
um it's a good film it's like Tremors
you know what I mean like like the first
Tremors film just like an instant sci-fi
cult movie yeah I think it just it had
such a low budget it didn't get a great
distributor so it just didn't get put
out there by as many people now people
have gone back to it since James gun's
become huge and it's definitely got that
cult following even more so now yeah I'm
GNA have to watch it again I haven't
watched it in a few years but I only
actually watched it when it came out
because of Nathan fillian basing off the
back of firefly it was pretty much the
first thing he did after Firefly and um
and I just thought I've got to watch
this film this will be good it's not
really my sort of cup of tea I like um
you know I don't really watch horror
movies much but it's not is it's it's a
tongue and
cheek comedy almost not quite but um uh
you know there's this there one bit
where the woman has got um and she's
she's inflat because of the the worms
are inside it all things it's because I
can't remember what she says but it
cracked me up at the time just like if I
put on a few pounds or something but
it's just it's just one of those films
that's unexpectedly brilliant and the
effects are quite good as well because
they kept it more simple you know it's
nothing too complicated sort but um it's
like I would say it's like um like
Arachnophobia it had that sort of vibe
to it as well there just like makes you
jump occasionally but
um anyway what so we're in the last sort
of quarter of an hour or so we we won't
keep Tommy more than an hour and I've
got to go and cook tea always you gotta
go pee we all know it I don't have to
pee yet yet start to feel a little bit
of an
urge no I'm fine but um so what you guys
been watching this week what are we what
you looking forward to in the next
week guys in the comments as well you've
been watching stormy
so uh my girlfriend has dragged me into
wonderful
comedies uh this week I started binging
uh Brooklyn 99 Adam
Samberg very very funny that's one of
those that's one of those R shows that
gets better the longer it went on it
just got funny yeah it's I'm totally
enthralled can't wait to mow through all
eight seasons and then the other one is
hacks um oh nice another really really
great writing really great acting you
feel sorry for everybody half the stuff
they say is cringeworthy you know it's
just awesome it's just very very
excellent U and this last week you know
uh of course it was um Doctor Who
special number three loved it and for
all mankind right here from the uh from
my advisory
Council yeah For All Mankind was really
really good finally Ed
gets gets his um not actually but he
really did get his face slapped verbally
which well you mentioned Doctor Who so
obviously that was a big sci-fi event
and I know I know Parris and Tommy
haven't seen it yet um the he Army damn
we thought we knew you yeah just because
I'm British yeah just because you're
British you should watch do to and love
it Dam it like like te and um
apologizing for things that aren't your
fault
um but u i I really enjoyed this episode
I thought it was the best of the three
by a mile um Neil Patrick Harris was
brilliant in it I thought he was
fantastic um they still poked the woke
bear a couple of times but they did it
well and much better than the first two
episodes um it didn't bother me in the
slightest I thought it was funny um it
it was um yeah it didn't I thought the
first couple of episodes when they were
I think they were trying to make a point
and they sort of um but it it affected
the the flow of the show sort of thing
didn't in this at all um I just didn't
like the way they so what they've done
there they split the two do they' split
the doctors so spoilers um so we've got
two doctors now basically Dave ATT
tenants doctor still alive and he's
still got his own tardis um the new
doctor just got a hammer to the Tardis
and split that in half as well because
of a very random well the ological
mythological so so we did there was
something we did get a very important
piece of information a very important
piece of Dr hul Lore out of this that
last episode I haven't seen a lot of
mention about it on YouTube or anywhere
else but we now know that David tenants
doctor his underwear had
buttons very very fascinating we should
have a whole show about David tenants
button but we should wait for Matt to
come on because I'm pretty sure Matt
will be very animated about David
tenants underwear buttons he won't shut
up about it um I I am two doctors maybe
I about to get an
appointment
um and the spoilers warning was a little
bit late but I did I I did say it so so
is Hannah coming back dur the TV show is
Hannah uh the dad is in um thing isn't
he there but I think he's dead third
series I love that series h i don't
anyway so sometimes things catch my eye
in the comments just sture um I'm about
to start watching the third season of um
the thing with the thing Yellowstone my
God that's a good show um it's like
Cowboys it's East Enders and cowboys
merge together everyone's merging or
shagging and but it's a western as well
it's fantastic anyway um how about you
guys what you been watching or loving
this week
that what you binging at the
moment yeah sure uh I've been watching a
lot less I know the last couple weeks
I've had swaths of lists but ComiCon
kept me from seeing too too much and I'm
an episode be uh episode and a half
behind on Monarch I believe but I did
see Godzilla minus one which was great
um oh I saw the boy in the Heron and I
hadn't eaten for like 28 hours so I fell
asleep halfway through but what I saw
was great so I need to go see that again
um been eating for 22 hours are you sure
you didn't slip into a small comb I
don't know I was just fasting I fasted a
little too long I got in a comfy dark
room and I was like so yeah um not much
besides that honestly it's first I know
but not much I saw the advert for the
bird in the her and I might the boy in
the her and Sor I might I might give
that a go it's my my instinct was this
looks like those s a Japanese cartoon
but as it went on I was like oh no okay
maybe I give it a go um how about you
Tommy what you been doing well I'm I've
always been a bit of a copile more than
like a TV guy so other than the TV show
I grew up with like Stargate um I've got
a lot of blind spots in TV so I've
actually just started catching up on
some shows I missed out on um so it's
not sci-fi but I've been watching uh The
West Wing which uh turns out is as good
as everyone says it is
so yeah been I've been smashing that
lately literally watched the last
episode about three days ago no way oh
really really honestly I'd never watched
it all the way to the end and I watched
it when my wife to about season five and
she got a bit bored of it and she was
like I can't follow this they keep it
keeps jumping all over the place I can't
follow it so we we stopped watching it
and I thought I've got to finish it and
I literally finished the very very last
episode um yeah literally like Wednesday
or something oh W um I love I love that
Series so hard to follow but I love that
Series so good um but they do talk very
fast about American politics and every
sing like going I probably just don't
need
rewind it but I just won't
bother and it's like Christmas time
right so I'm just starting to amp up the
the Christmas movies so probably gonna
start that tomorrow night watch a
Christmas movie a night or something you
know yeah I tell you what it's a good
film um
Genie with um oh yeah Richard Curtis
wrote that right Richard Curtis wrote it
yeah um it's got
umy thank you Melissa McCarthy in it um
my wife made me watch it and I went into
it with linking H God okay fine well I
don't like Melissa McCarthy particularly
she's kind of irritates me a little bit
um but it's actually very good it's a
really nice Christmas movie quite it's
almost
funny it's a comedy but um it's you know
it's like um it's funny it's just not
haha funny you know thing I mean it's
just it's just nice he's come out go oh
I want go hug Santa or
something um didn't you say you'd seen
Wonka I and I saw Wonka yesterday okay
and also a lovely movie um it's it's
actually the sequel or a prequel that
the original deserved I think it's an
instant classic I thought it was great
the songs are really good and when he
they do finally break out out into come
with me and we'll and you'll be in a
world of pure at the end you're probably
like I'm not crying I'm
fine it's it's properly like get you
gets you get you there sort
thing it's a good film and the guy from
June that kid is astonishingly good he's
so good I mean following Jee Wilder in
that movie is
[Music]
um yeah woner is directed and produced
by the guys that
did and it shows because I mean a lot of
the actors come back through um but the
songs are actually good which again for
a musical nowadays she do to like and
they're very forgettable they're not
they're actually quite good they're
quite catchy um it is funny um it's
obviously got British actors in it so
it's well acted um barely any Americans
in it at all which is just I think is a
is a is a benefit to
it nothing nothing at all try poke
I can't wait to see it just because of I
will watch him do anything at the moment
I think he's remarkable talent for the
last few years I can't wait to see it
it's it's it's honestly worth it it's it
might be my favorite film this
year I would I I've absolutely I I
adored it and I don't really like
musicals um particularly not Star Trek
musicals they can they can go away um
but um but it's it's um it's it's just a
lovely lovely film actually it really
deserves every every plot it
gets it's that good um good I'd watch it
again I'm not gonna pay to watch it
again but I'd watch it again i' got a
membership actually with Odin so I can
go for free so I'm just go go get screw
um G own except I threw my popcorn on
the floor so I had a bag with popcorn
and I put my chocolate in the front and
we've got this little table on our odian
cinnamon and as I I so I at my chocolate
not think that the weight was then
shifted to the back and I just saw the
Bago so apologized to the guy sat next
to me I'm like yeah you're going to be
picking popcorn out at the bottom of
your shoe for the next hour
sorry wife was like do you want mine you
got salted I salted Salted
Popcorn so so I just had to go that but
I eat nor my
chocolate
bonus anyway so uh um stormmy have you
got anything else before
we uh that was it
um you know I've been I've been gone
mostly this uh last week um went off to
the Grand Canyon and went to the very
large array where contact was filmed
this last week went to Petrified Forest
went to Carl's Bad Caverns went to the
Guadalupe Mountains National Park uh
went to one other place yeah meteor crat
natural monument in
Arizona yeah and I went to
Roswell yeah yeah yeah I was gonna be up
but
failed I love Roswell I'm fine yes it
is don't s your s yourself again please
most West
Wing act I think Roo just plays Robo
does him does he ever it's a bit like
um oh his name's gone I'm terrible with
lives because I'm trying to juggle so
many things in my brain um he's an actor
that um he was in rank andar Rock he's
he's brilliant to the FL gold Blum gold
Blum always just plays Jeff Goldblum but
he does it so brilliantly that nobody
notices he's not acting he's just he's
just coming on and talk reading the
lines of being himself
um and and I just love that and I think
Rob L's like I don't I don't think
roblow is I think he just do himself but
I don't think robow did Rob low in
californation SE oh there was yes his
description of giving head to a man I
don't think was very
roblow I know roblo is a womanizer but I
my wife had to explain this to me about
a month ago because I thought roblo was
gay I thought roblo was married to
another and I thought he was gay but I
don't have no idea where I got that from
I don't care either way it's not one of
those things like I don't like I'm just
my wife is like no there's been a load
of rumors about him for years like is
it I still don't care but he learn
something new every day yeah um he's
great parks and wreck he's one of the
best characters in parks and wreck yeah
he is playing himself but it's like the
exact mated version of himself which is
so great it's so funny
yeah I've never actually watched Parks I
should literally the best thing I have
to do it over again have some bits
season season one's quite rough um yeah
I know a lot of shows are like that but
it the the kind of jump from season one
season two is huge in Po and wck it gets
so much better right I love and
and I love him and love
him yeah he's so funny he's he's
fantastic um and obviously you know you
got got Chris in it and stuff but yeah
okay I'll give it a go I need I need my
next binge series after I've watched
Travelers
so that it might have to be parks and
wreck it's on Disney plus I think pretty
sure it is I think it was on Hulu so it
should be right yeah everything on over
here anything on Hulu's discuss TR we
haven't got Hulu so it goes Disney
plus so like prey was just on Disney
plus and things like that so so so what
we got going on in our respective
channels I mean what are you coming up
with uh Harris this week well should I I
mentioned it earlier in chat should
should we it's not official yet but
Jamie and I are talking about this
Wednesday for Cinema scoop we're going
to do another presidential debate styled
video and we're going to shoot for Greg
coming back on this Wednesday so Greg
will debate in the side of sag
ratification and Jamie will debate
against sag ratif no no no he no didn't
he he voted no Jamie will be voting yes
yes that's what I meant to if we're
gonna do that you really need to get on
it then because I need to prepare you
can't do that Wednesday I need to
prepare so yeah yeah but um yeah right
now I know it's might sound weird in
this might shock you guys but I quite
like
arguing I don't know if that's ever come
up and so yeah no that'll be great we'll
do that and we'll we'll we'll stream it
on on on both channels and we'll have a
bit of fun with that and see if we can
because he's a very passionate guy we're
gonna have to put a timer on him though
to shut him up and I'm a passionate guy
so you G have to put a timer on me to
shut me up so and I'm being strict with
these timers every which way now I I'm
after I lost the first one uh because of
poll openings staying open till I could
lose um we're being very all I'm saying
is there might be an element of this is
my damn
Channel just put up with
it and now we're doing it on
both yeah I can't get away with that
crap when it's on your channel as well I
can't get away with it so um but I won
so AR every about tell me what's what's
coming up on the companion sir uh well
we're less than a week away from the
companion holiday special now which is
next Saturday with Brad Riot and uh a
bunch of fun segments and stuff to be
honest of you I'm uh not I've not been
producing this one so I don't even know
all of the fun surprises that we've got
store but I just know that they've been
in development for a little while and
they're gonna they're going to be fun
segment so yeah look forward to that I
think it's 11:00 a.m. Pacific Time 2 pm
Eastern Time 700 p.m. greinwich meantime
um yeah cool uh I did put put links on
yesterday's video but I haven't for
today sorry so if you want links to that
they're all on yesterday's video go
check it out and Yeah set your remind
for because it's gonna be on YouTube
it's completely free anybody can watch
it you don't have to be a companion um
member I'm appearing in it for one
second um or or 17 seconds I think it
was that yeah I just just genely me
being silly again um and yeah um Brad
Wright's promised me a shout out so Tom
if he doesn't do it you know just remind
him so I might watch it and just
constantly go you promised
Brad um so yeah
uh so yeah just like a Merry Christmas
that I'm gonna throw in our at some
point yeah how about you any ideas any
let's see Wednesday I've got a a new um
well it's not new it's a it's an old
vintage radio track back it's the
impostor by Philip K dick um really good
show coming out on Wednesday Wednesday
on Professor crit that's a great story I
I I read that when I was like 12 or
something it's proper mind bending it
originally came out an astounding uh
science fiction I think in the
50s really good story really good I mean
Phil dick he's not a slouch everything
he wrote was really really good yeah
anyway when
uh on Sidetrack you've got the 12 days
of Stargate coming up where I
sing God help song bird of a
generation song bird of a generation oh
yeah yeah I mean I'm I'm thinking Mariah
Carey eating my shorts um downloaded
number one by the end of the week right
so um but I I've taken the 12 Days of
Christmas and I've completely Rewritten
it and I tell you what the 12 Days of
Christmas is is quite hard to sing so
when I get to the 12
days no you can hear when I'm running
out of breath it's like and and by the
time you get to the you can't breathe
until you hit five golden rings
so it's not it's not
easy um but I I did it
on well I did it on a nice software that
messed with my tone and and pitch and
stuff so that that's out Wednesday
because it's actually out 12 days before
Christmas clever I like it we've had I
literally had an interesting email just
before we went on that I'll find out a
bit more about so I might have a video
about the expanse and a few rumors on
that coming up but I need to find out a
little bit more first um so we'll we'll
see about that in the week and then uh
tomorrow's video that I started editing
and I was nearly late for you guys today
because I was editing and wasn't
watching the time was um perfect Sci-Fi
movies so movies that are absolute
perfection I've picked my five then I'm
sort of explaining why they're perfect
what makes a perfect movie and because
you know I don't use the word uh Loosely
basically or lightly I should say it's
um so why we all five of them
Interstellar not no Interstellar
wouldn't even make my conversation mate
you know what I think about interstella
why do you why why why why you got to
poke the bear
[Music]
want to be tickle tickle like that poke
him this made me angry um interstella is
shockingly bad movie I do I do not get
the fascination with interstella you
know what the best thing about
Interstellar was all the okra died all
of it the okra was gone there was no
more
okra okra [__] hate okra oh God it's
terrible think all kale died off as
well screw you kale what are you even
for scre you
kale um but but yeah so um I know I'm
not a big fan of inst Stella uh Stupid
fil so good anyway no it's like it's one
of those things they say oh we're
scientifically accurate not
really
and is the bloody robots doing that and
I'm like fall over fall over you'd fall
over
anyway let's leave it right guys thank
you so so much um we we We've ran over
by four minutes so I think we can
live colon O'Neal we've run over by four
minutes but never
mind thank you Tommy so much for coming
on mate I hope it's not the the the
first and only I hope we get to see you
again at some point fascinating insight
as well and really interesting opinion
so love it um thank having me had a
great time well you're very very welcome
thank you for thank you for coming
normally we try to do little um we have
like a something to actually talk about
but we just thought we chill out tonight
I think um we're not back next weekend
by the way guys sorry I just remembered
because it's my wedding anniversary so
I've got to go away with the wife for
two
days she's probably gonna watch rumpy
pumpy and stuff and I'm was like oh God
we've been married rumpy pumpy what did
you say rumpy
pumpy
rumpy bumpy
um she's going to want us to anyway do
stuff uh but no it's my wedding
anniversary so yeah we've got a very
nice hotel we're going away for a couple
of days and oh good good good good good
good so we won't we won't be but then
the week after that is going to be our
Christmas special we're going to do
something I don't know what but we'll
think of something um as you said go and
check out the companions holiday special
it's not going to be like the Star Wars
holiday special it'll be better than
that um it'll be it'll be better than
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special as well which was also bloody
awful um Harris stormy thank you so much
as always guys you've been absolutely
brilliant um legendary as normal I have
to Waffle for two seconds while I find
the end credit bit there we go found it
say byebye everybody goodbye
everybody
bye